وبعد الهجمات الاوكرانيه على القرم قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات صاروخيه عاليه
الدقه ووصفتها بالانتقاميه على منشات
اوكرانيه لتصنيع قوارب مسيره في منطقه
واضاف ان هذه المسيرات كانت تتجهز لشن
هجمات وصفها بالارهابي ضد روسيا
سعوديا
نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه خلال الليل
ضربه شامله انتقاميه باسلحه بحريه عاليه
الدقه على منشاه يتم فيها التحضير لاعمال
ارهابيه ضد روسيا باستخدام قوارب مسيره
وايضا على مواقع لصناعه تلك القوارب في
حوض لبناء السفن بالقرب من مدينه اوديسا
بالاضافه الى ذلك تم تدمير مستودعات
لتخزين الوقود في
مقاطعتيا تبلغ ساعتها نحو 70 الف طن تم
منها تزويد المعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
بالوقود
على الجانب الاوكراني قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه اطلقت خمسه
صواريخ الثلاثمائه وستين صاروخا من انواع
مختلفه وقالت وسائل الاعلام روسيا للقوات
الروسيه شنت هجوما صاروخيا وصفته بالكبير
على مدن
اوديسايف واخر كيف الاوكرانيه ونشرت صورا
قالت انها للهجوم الصاروخي الذي شنته
القوات الروسيه على المدن الاوكرانيه
الثلاث
وفي غضون ذلك قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
اندريه ان الهجوم الروسيه الذي وقع ليلا
على اوديسايف باستخدام الصواريخ والطائرات
من نوع الشاهد دليل اخر على انها دوله
ارهابيه وفق تعبيره واضاف في بيان ان
الهجمات الروسيه تعرض حياه 400 مليون
انسان للخطر في دول مختلفه ممن يعتمدون
على الصادرات الغذائيه الاوكرانيه
ويجب على العالم وفق قوله ان يفهم بان هدف
روسيا هو التجويع وقتل البشر وخلق موجات
لجوء جديده للضغط على الغرب ومحاوله
اضعافه
ومن جانب اخر نقلت وكاله رينو الروسيه عن
مصدر دبلوماسيين تركيين قوله ان انقره
تلقت مقترحا منك لاستئناف صفقه الحبوب دون
موسكو وهو معلق عليه الكريملم بالقول عند
الامر محفوف بالمخاطر في غياب ضماناتنا
امنيه وتاما الكرم للنظام كيف باستخدام
تنفيذ صفقه الحبوب لاغراض عسكريه
معنى من دونتسك مراسله الجزيره امين
درغامي ومعنى من كرامات مراسل الجزيره
مازن ابراهيم وابدا
بامين درغامي وهذا الاعلان الروسي عن
استهداف مصنع للزوارق المسيره في اوديسا
بجانب هجمات اخرى وتفاصيل سير المعارك وفق
الروايه الروسيه
نعم زين هذا الاعلان عن شن هجوم الليلي
بصواريخ قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
عاليه الدقه على اهداف قرب ميناء اوديسا
جاءت ساعات قليله فقط بعد اعلان الوزاره
ايضا على انها صدت هجوما كبيرا
بالمصيرات الاوكرانيه على اهداف في شبه
جزيره القمه الليله الماضيه وهو الهجوم
الثالث على بعد ثلاثه ايام على التوالي
على اهداف في شبه جزر القمر وياتي طبعا
بعد يوم واحد فقط على الهجوم على جسر
القرن الذي ادى الى مقتل مدنيين وما تلا
من ذلك من تحذير روسي بان الرد سيكون قويا
على ذلك الهجوم ودعوه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وزاره الدفاع الى تحضير رد
مناسب على ذلك الهجوم الاوكراني طبعا
بالاضافه الى ما جرى الليله الماضيه حول
شبه الجزيره القرن وايضا في مقاطعتي
القوات الروسيه امس شنت هجمات على مواقع
اخرى في مقاطعات عده من بينها خاركيف
الجزء الخادع طبعا للسيطره الاوكرانيه في
اخرسون وزاباروجيا وبتوازي مع ذلك هناك
عمليات عسكريه متواصله تقول وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اليوم ان قواتها تقدمت بنحو
كيلومترين في عمق جبهه محور كوبيانسك
بمقاطعه خارقيب وبان تلك الجبهه الان تشهد
لربما امساك من قبل القوات الروسيه بزمام
المبادره خلال اليومين الماضيين هناك ايضا
معارك تحدثت عنها مصادر عسكريه روسيه صباح
اليوم عنيفه بين الجانبين في شمال وفي
جنوب مدينه باخمود دون الحديث عن اي تغير
في خريطه السيطره بين الجانبين على تلك
المواقع وايضا هنا في دونياسك عبر قصف
موضعي متبادل بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني وصلت نيرانه ما يبدو الى اطراف
مدينه دانياس كالسلطات المواليه لروسيا
هنا اليوم زين اكدت مقتل مدنيين اثنين
وجرح ثلاثه اخرين جراء قصف مدفعي اوكراني
على مدينه دنيسكو على بعض البلدات القريبه
ايضا من خط المواجهه الرئيسي جنوبا تحدثت
اليوم مصادر عسكريه روسيه على ان الدفاعات
الجويه جنوبه مقاطعه خرسون تمكنت من اسقاط
طائره مسيره تركيا الصنع من طراز بيرقدار
واشارت الى ان هذا المعطى الجديد لربما
يشير الى
دخول او عوده لنقل مسيرات بيرقدار الى
ساحه المعركه وهو المره الاولى التي
تستخدم فيها القوات او تستهدف فيها القوات
الروسيه هذا النوع من المسيرات منذ الاشهر
ولربما الاسابيع الاولى لهذه الحرب العام
الماضي